hello this is a demo of the new flash
format feature that we've developed for
powerpoint so a lot of the time
PowerPoint users need to make repetitive
changes throughout a document and flash
format allows them to make these changes
by example let's say we have the
presentation here with many slides with
diagrams on them and let's say that the
user would like to make a repetitive
change such as changing the color of all
the diamond shapes in the presentation
into yellow so he can do that using
flash format by first going to the flash
format tab at the top and then there are
two buttons here start new examples and
flash format so before starting a
repetitive editing talk the user can
click the start Neil examples button to
indicate that he's about to give new
examples to the system and then he can
give a few examples of the
transformation that he would like to
make so let's say in this case he wants
to change color of the diamond shapes
into yoga and maybe he wants to change
the color of the text and to lose so he
gives two examples of that and then
going back to the flash format tab if he
clicks flash format the system tries to
infer a generalization from those
examples and applies it throughout the
presentation so in this case the system
infers that the the user wants to change
all the diamond shapes and the
presentation and display
now the user can also undo the changes
made by flash format in the standard way
using the undo button or just clicking
controls it now if the user doesn't want
the transformation to be applied to the
whole presentation then they can select
certain parts of the presentation maybe
they select certain objects and then if
they click flash format after selecting
those then the changes are just applied
to those objects or they can select
certain slides in the side panel over
here and selecting those slides there is
a question on whether you want to apply
only to those slides and into the yes
then only the shapes on those slides
would be conformed and if there is no
selection made and the user clicks flash
format then the changes are made in the
whole document so let's undo that all of
those changes and let's look at another
example so the transformation that is
inferred by the system very much depends
on the examples that the user gives so
let's say that the user is not
interested in the shape of the object
but instead of once to highlight any
shape that has underlined text and
divided so in this case it gives four
examples of that and then clicking flash
format the system inferred that any
shape that contains underline text
should be highlighted in this way so the
transformation very much depends on the
examples of the user gives and the more
examples the user gives the better and
usually three or four examples are
sufficient flash format also works
incrementally so if at this point the
user would like to apply the
transformation more generally then he
can just click the flash format button
again and the system then tries to apply
the transformation or generally to set
more similar shapes
so in this case we see that all the
diamonds and the gray boxes have been
changed and if we click flash format
again then we see that all the red boxes
now have also changed so the the system
generalizes further it's more times you
click flash format however let's say
that the user at this point it did not
want all the red boxes to change then
you can undo that last change and he can
give more examples to guide the system
further so let's say he wants to change
only all the no boxes so you can give
two more examples of no boxes and then
apply this transformation more generally
by clicking flash format again and that
causes the system to change all the no
boxes in the presentation similarly at
this point if the user wants to be
further examples you can maybe change
all the es boxes as well and then
clicking flash format again to
generalize to Paul the S boxes in the
presentation so in this way the user can
guide the system through the
generalization process so that's the
thing that the user is now happy with
all of these changes made and once to
charge a new repetitive tongue then you
can go up to the top here and click the
start new examples button again and that
would clear all of the previous examples
and we can start giving me examples
let's say now the user wants to make
certain formatting changes to arrows in
the presentation so again he clicks on a
few examples and maybe he wants to
increase the thickness of these arrows
and maybe he wants to change the arrow
type so pretty much any of the
formatting features available in
PowerPoint could be used and then having
given three examples the applied flash
format to the whole presentation and we
see in this case it's only the straight
line arrows that have changed because
all of the examples of the user gave or
of straight line errors so at this point
if the user wants to apply generally to
all the arrows in the present
station then you can select one of these
elbow connectors as an example and apply
flash format to that and having given
one example of that you can further
generalize by clicking flash format
again and we see that that causes all of
the arrows in the presentation to change
in the same way so let's look at another
example presentation in this case we
have any slides with headings and text
boxes let's say the user wants to make
some changes to the headings on every
flight so he clicks starting an example
and again format texting like underlying
Daleks maybe even rotate the text box a
little bit and given one example in this
case we click flash format and that
applies the changes throughout the whole
presentation so let's look at an example
with bullet points let's say we change
the type of this circular purple bullet
point into into a different type and
then we go to another slide and we
select an object and we click flash
format and that applies is changed to
only the circular purple bullets and the
subject however if the user wants to
apply the formatting more generally to
the subject then you can select it and
then click flash format again and the
system would then try to apply to
formatting more generally so the first
the system first asks the user if he
would like to apply it again to the
selected object because it's already
been formatted and if the user says yes
then the system apply is the same kind
of formatting to all the bullet points
and this object so flash format can also
be applied incrementally within objects
flash format also supports text
transformations which is based on an
integration with the flash fill
technology from Excel so in this case we
have a slide with lots of names on it
and let's say we want to change these
first names into just the initials then
we can give a couple of examples of that
and you click flash format and the
system applies the same kind of change
to all the names in the presentation
which is based on an analysis of both
textual and formatting properties of the
objects so here's another example in
which we have a presentation with many
values with trailing digits throughout
the presentation so let's say we want to
turn these trailing digits into into sub
scripts and so again we give a few
examples of that you choose X with
different colors
we give three examples of that in this
case clicking flash format again using
the textual properties and the
formatting properties the system in fur
is a generalization and applies the same
change throughout presentation training
all the trailing digits into subscript
flat format can also be used to do
global alignment and positioning changes
so let's say we want to change the
position of visible group of objects
relative to where it was before so we
give examples by doing that on one slide
then you click flash format we see that
the same kind of positioning changes are
happening happen throughout all the
slides and notice that not all of the
objects are changed in the same ways and
it's only the objects that fall under
the generalization of the examples that
were given flash format can also be used
to align object correctly across flight
so if you look at the the map table text
box in this case we see that it is not
aligned correctly in the different slide
and so if the user would like to fix
that then he can again click start game
examples and maybe he aligns it
correctly on the first slide and then
clicking flash format with just one
example it is of now aligned correctly
across all the site so those are some of
the things you can do using flash format
and please contact us if you have any
further questions thank you